there's a really interesting debate
happening within my audience within you
fine folks and the debate is
is it better or worse
if republicans
right wingers trumpists marjorie taylor
greene mike lindell and others is it
better or worse
if they really believe trump's lies and
the lies being told by republicans about
the 2020 election or whatever
or if they don't believe them but repeat
them anyway which is worse in terms of
what it means about them as people about
the american political landscape about
humanity quite frankly and the jumping
off point for this debate was actually
the story that i did yesterday where we
uh talked about a text message that was
leaked from my pillow ceo mike lindell
to donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows the text messages from
shortly after the 2020 election and it's
a very long the text message is almost
as long as one of those cvs receipts you
know six seven feet long and in the text
message mike lindell at least appears to
really believe trump won he's got the
evidence he's got the machines he's got
all the different stuff and he texts
mark meadows and says we've got to keep
fighting and let's do this and let's do
that so at least apparently it seemed to
be sort of like the proof we were
looking for to tell us that mike pillow
is not just saying this stuff he
genuinely sincerely deeply believes it
and the video got close to a hundred
thousand views in the first few hours
and it's a story of great interest to
many of you
there's basically two perspectives here
one view is
this text message proves that mike
pillow
really believes it and that this makes
him to quote one of our viewers less
psychotic
because if it were true that trump
really won the election if and it were
stolen right imagine that it were true
that biden stole it from trump if it
were true
it would be logical that if you care
about democracy you would be doing
everything you can to get the word out
you would be spending if you're mike
pillow and you have the money
you'd be spending your money to try to
prove
that indeed it was stolen and to try to
overturn it in other words
if pillow and others
didn't really believe the election was
stolen but they were out there saying it
anyway they would be truly depraved and
dishonest whereas if they really believe
it but they're wrong
they're just wrong they're less nutty in
a sense that's one perspective that
people in the audience had
now the problem with
really believing it is that it's
absolutely horrifying that people could
fall for something so obviously untrue
so it's disturbing and it's dystopian
but in a different way now there's
another perspective
and that perspective came through in
some of the responses i got
which is even though mike pillow did
text this to mark meadows
it really still doesn't prove that
pillow is a believer and the idea there
was
pillow was knowingly planting stuff so
that later if it came out it would look
like he was a true believer i actually
find that sort of hard to believe to be
honest having spoken to and interviewed
mike pillow on the show and we've been
observing him now for you know a couple
years since the start of the pandemic
it's i just don't think that that's how
he operates but it's theoretically
possible it's completely speculative now
there's another set of people who are
focusing on the money that pillow spent
as kind of the proof and it's true that
he has spent a bunch of money pushing
all of these different challenges and
getting voting machines and paying i.t
people and all of this stuff and for
what why has he been spending all of
that money
a supposedly sane person
might spend you know you spend your
first hundred grand on this nonsense
and then you realize this isn't going to
work to put trump back in office trump's
now been out of office for closer to two
years i'm gonna give up the spending and
every single week he's making some
promise he obviously can't keep and so
he must be a true believer because no
reasonable person would keep
hemorrhaging money for something that's
obviously going nowhere there's no
reward in sight it makes no sense he
must believe it and just be out of his
gourd
another reaction was well you know with
mike pillow you've got to consider his
history of addiction it's widely known
he had serious drug addiction issues and
a few of you wrote to me saying you
probably have
based on what we know about his drug
addiction he probably has a generally
addictive personality and addictive
personalities thrive on positive
feedback loops and pillow is getting
enough positive reaction he goes to
these trump rallies and he says we're
about to do it we're suing all machines
or we're about to file
uh you know uh a preliminary adjunction
as he likes to say a preliminary
injunction and everybody cheers and that
might be the addictive personality
positive feedback loop that keeps him
going independently of whether he
believes it or not he says it and the
crowd cheers and it's like you got a
jackpot on a slot machine for a gambling
addict okay that's an interesting idea
but let's step back a little bit
the topic of a true believer and a false
believer in the context of cults
this is a cult
has been actually studied academically
cult experts and others
who are the more more dangerous ones are
the true believers more dangerous or are
the false believers more dangerous and
the con concept is basically as follows
with any cult-like movement
you have some false believers and what
we mean by a false believer is someone
who declares their commitment to the
ideology or to the leader or to whatever
they declare their ideology in order to
have membership and that's it they don't
they don't believe it any further than
that that's one those are the false
believers you then have the true
believers who genuinely believe this
stuff and you can look at any cult and
you find examples of this you look at
the jim jones people's temple there were
people who were very very borderline
they didn't really believe this stuff
literally but they kind of wanted to be
part of the group so we see that in just
about every cult and there's also the
other side of it which is do the leaders
prefer true or false believers in the
case of trumpism which is what we're
talking about
the false believers have basically been
welcomed we know
there are tons of republicans who are
and have been anti-trump privately we
found out after the fact usually but as
long as they profess their allegiance
and keep their mouth shut trump and
others in the upper echelon seem
basically fine with it now of course as
soon as it's known that they don't
really believe you get kicked out you
get attacked you get excoriated but
that's a different story so there's a
term called true believer syndrome and
it has a specific meaning this was
coined by lamar keane
and true believers are people who
continue to believe in a paranormal
event or a phenomenon or something that
took place
even after it's been proven to have been
staged or untrue now at this point in
the real world not in nutty wherever but
in the real factual empirical world
we could almost call
we could call
the claim that trump actually won in
2020 it's now like it's it's now a
paranormal belief it's a false event it
didn't really happen we know it we know
that that's not true
and hilariously
keen considered
true believer syndrome to be a cognitive
disorder and we could debate whether
that's the case or not so at the end of
the day i don't have the answer as to
whether the true believers or the false
believers are more dangerous we've said
of the people who continue to claim
trump won
some literally believe it and some say
it to show allegiance to the group
and i don't know who's more dangerous i
want to hear from you you tell me
which group do you think poses more of a
threat
i want to talk about a bit of news from
a few days ago which is quite
interesting there is now a report that
president joe biden told former
president barack obama
that he is going to run in 2024 that joe
biden will run for re-election in 2024.
there's a report in the guardian from a
few days ago
which has a sub-headline the president
joe biden thinks he's the only one who
can beat trump according to what a
source told the hill as trump readies
his own third run the article reads joe
biden has told barack obama he will run
for re-election in 2024 according to
washington website the hill
the site cited two anonymous sources one
was quoted as saying biden wants to run
and he's clearly letting everyone know
it wasn't clear when biden told obama
his plan but obama did visit the white
house earlier this month to celebrate
the affordable care act
um we know that
joe biden used to be the vice president
at 78 biden was the oldest president
ever inaugurated if he won again he
would be 82 at the start of a second
term
in september it was widely reported
biden and aids told allies he planned to
run again
in december biden said he would run if
he stayed in good health
he also said kamala harris his vp would
be on the ticket again
in a december interview with abc biden
said another trump candidacy would
increase the prospect of running
in brussels in march
biden referred to trump when he said in
the next election i'd be very fortunate
if i had the same man running against me
do i think joe biden is going to run
again i actually don't know i
at this point
i believe that joe biden has to say
it is my intention to run for reelection
i i don't have any doubt that that is
the correct thing to say it would be
problematic for his presidency now to
say i'm not even going to run again it
would be an a news cycle a serious news
cycle
it would interfere with whatever it is
joe biden plans to try to do and what's
left of his first term
so i think that no matter what his
intentions are this is what he would be
saying right now whether he will
ultimately run i don't know
now the question of who could beat trump
we actually do have some polling and i
know that looking at polling this early
is a bit fraught but we have a number of
different uh polls which um
can give us some information many of
these are from the last few days in a
hypothetical biden versus trump matchup
the morning consult politico poll has
biden 45 and trump 44.
now
you could argue that's not great because
trump isn't even really a candidate you
could also say trump really kind of is a
candidate because everybody thinks he's
running in an insider advantage poll
a trump is defeating biden 4743
there's a yougov yahoo news poll where
it's biden 43 trump 41.
um and then there's also other polls
like bernie versus trump where trump
bests bernie by one in morning consult
so i don't know
that these polls at this point given
that we don't know if biden's running
and we don't know if trump is running i
don't know how much they tell us other
than
it's not obvious anybody's going to run
away with it i think that's the fair
takeaway from what we have from polling
so far if it's biden versus trump
there's a fight and either candidate
could win if it's not trump and it's
kamala harris
it's conceivable that uh either one
could win if it's not trump or biden and
instead it's for example harris desantis
as the harris pole asked
right now it's harris plus four so i
think it's too early for any of these
polls to tell us anything definitive
other than there's uncertainty about who
the candidates will be
and there's a real question mark as to
who voters would in theory rally behind
i think that we just don't know what i
want to hear from you
is do you think biden should run for
re-election let us know in a youtube
comment
find me on twitter at dpakman or on any
of our other platforms next week we'll
do a kind of reaction segment and see
what folks are thinking
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support i would love for you to sign up
at joinpacman.com
get a membership get the extra bonus
show every single day
and get a commercial free audio and
video feed of the show every single day
up to six hours before the daily show is
published
joinpakman.com is the place to sign up
you can use the coupon code wow 22 for a
discount this is absolutely fascinating
um the amount of uh potential
criminality that radical repugnant
republican congressman madison cawthorne
has been engaged in is very high we
talked yesterday about him bringing a
knife to a school board meeting and now
being caught with guns twice at airports
the latest is that madison cawthorne
appears to be implicated in an insider
trading scheme
and also may have violated the stock act
by failing to disclose a let's go
brandon cryptocurrency purchase now
we're gonna go through the details of
the two stories in a moment
but it can't be ignored
that there very clearly seems to be a
concerted effort from the right to
damage madison cawthorne kawthorne a few
weeks ago made headlines by saying he'd
been invited to cocaine-fueled orgies by
fellow members of congress the
republican party didn't like that it
potentially is true either way it
doesn't matter
they seem to now be
uh targeting madison cothorn and the uh
the targeting is being done by
republicans so let's start first with an
article in the washington examiner this
is a right-wing publication madison
cauthor implicated in potential insider
trading scheme experts say
madison cawthon may have violated
federal insider trading laws as he hyped
up an alleged pump and dump
cryptocurrency scheme multiple watchdog
groups told the washington examiner on
december 29th the beleaguered north
carolina congressman posed at a party
with james katulis a hedge fund manager
and the ringleader of the let's go
brandon cryptocurrency a meme coin set
up in the wake of the chant mocking joe
biden
um cawthorne posted on instagram
let's go brandon legends tomorrow we go
to the moon
the next day lgb coin went bonkers
and the value spiked by 75 percent
multiple watchdog groups told the
washington examiner that the post
suggests he may have had advanced
non-public knowledge
of lgb coin's deal
the watchdog said the post combined with
a statement that he owns the coin
warrant and investigation this looks
really really bad said the government
affairs manager for project on
government oversight similarly
um
he may have violated what's called the
stock act remember insider training
trading and the stock act are two
different things they are related often
when it comes to members of congress
the stock act applies specifically to
members of congress insider trading laws
apply
more generally to everybody but as a
member of congress he may have access to
particular information so there are two
stories here there's the story itself
about madison cothorn insider trading
violating the stock act bringing guns to
airports all of these um legal issues
and the general question as to whether
he's going to be held accountable for
any of it now of course
everybody's innocent until proven guilty
my position unlike the people who go
lock her up lock up hillary wait a
second hillary hasn't been charged and
she hasn't been found guilty you can't
lock her up so i don't say lock up
madison hawthorne i say
there certainly is smoke here so there
should be an investigation and the
investigation should take us where it
will and on that basis if he committed
crimes he should be charged he shouldn't
be exempt from being charged because
he's a member of congress the political
story that is very interesting
is the obviously
concerted effort by the republican party
to oust madison cothorn when the
washington examiner is publishing dirt
on a conservative on a republican i
shouldn't call him a conservative on a
neo-reactionary republican
it may be a signal that the
establishment republican party is done
with him and every indication is that
the cocaine fueled orgy story is what
sort of put this over the edge and we'll
see what madison cawthorne's future
holds i don't know the answer but at
minimum right now there is plenty of
smoke telling us there should be
numerous criminal investigations going
on we'll follow it we'll see where it
goes
we have been starting to pay closer
attention to particular 2022 midterm
races we're following
just to name a few the florida
gubernatorial race where potential 2024
presidential candidate ron desantis is
up for re-election as governor
we on monday night
had a live stream of in the pennsylvania
senate we first had the democratic
primary debate
and then we had the republican primary
debate the republican primary debate is
the one where mehmet oz the um
uh
tv doctor
is running we covered that and it was
cringy and it was wacky in a lot of
different ways
another particularly disturbing race
is the arizona house race
wherein in the first arizona
congressional district a guy named ron
watkins is running we've talked about
ron watkins before uh ron watkins is a
a roughly
35 34 year old conspiracy theorist he's
the site administrator administrator and
um uh i guess we i think he's the owner
as well of the website 8k un this is
formerly 8chan
and he has played a major role in
spreading all sorts of far-right q anon
conspiracy theories he is now running
in arizona's first congressional
district he was in a debate last night
hosted by arizona state university and
the local pbs station and there is
something about this guy
that is cringe-worthy
and extraordinarily creepy i don't know
exactly what it is i'm going to look at
a couple of clips here with you first
just a very strange moment from his
opening statement where he kind of seems
to lose his train of thought but it's
all just weird and i will make sure that
your rights are
are kept
thank you okay so the enti the entire
thing got off to a very very strange
start
now then the question of ukraine came up
military aid to ukraine
ron watkins tried to blame the keystone
xl pipeline
for the invasion
and this um
led to one of the other candidates
representative blackman
uh to basically crush watkins and he
crushed him so brutally that watkins had
no choice to go actually i misspoke my
opponent is correct this is fascinating
check this out terry aid to ukraine what
do you think ron i support military uh
aides ukraine but i wanna say that we
would not even be in ukraine
if president biden did not shut down the
keystone pipeline on the first day why
because
now that that's shut down we have to get
our oil and we're getting it from russia
and we're getting
all these problems through the ukraine
and that would not have happened if uh
biden did not see the ukraine so this is
a word salad this is of no he is visibly
struggling to use english to communicate
substance and he is failing
the
the pipeline
helped prompt russia to invade ukraine
yes sir because we've got all of this
oil coming through from russia to the
united states and they want the better
routes to bring the oil through can i
can i clarify
this is what i'm talking about that's
not why they went into ukraine ukraine
they went into ukraine because ukraine
didn't want to be part of nato listen
you're trying to be you're trying to
work on the national stage and you don't
even know why the war started in ukraine
it had nothing to do with the keystone
pipeline the keystone pipeline caused
the inflation and the increase in our
gas prices now that reason why that's
also not true that so they're both wrong
but but i mean this this is just bizarre
they went in to ukraine is because
russia
wanted ukraine as they had him pre-world
war ii and ukraine wanted to be part of
nato respond please
he's right i made a mistake yeah there
you go so i mean
listen
if there's anything to praise ron
watkins for here
um
it's that he immediately said yeah what
i just said is completely untrue it's
absolutely and completely untrue in
another weird moment ron watkins claimed
that the biggest issue in uh the
congress is it the first or second
congressional dis now i don't even
remember they he said that the biggest
issue is the border wall even though
this part of arizona isn't actually near
the border
and then he claims that he went to the
border and scared coyotes away coyotes
not literal
actually i think he means coyotes in
terms of like people smugglers i don't
think he means literal coyotes but let's
listen biggest issue for this district
is the border wall the border wall was
not completed and there are actually
sections of it that were destroyed
and i went down to those sections and i
asked the locals how did this section of
the boardwalk get destroyed right and
they told me that biden sent the army
corps of engineers down there to destroy
the border wall for flood for flood
prevention
issues so i went down there and i saw
with my own eyes i saw the coyotes
sitting right across the border the
coyotes looked me in the eyes and they
ran away right they were so scared when
when uh ron watkins went down there so
bizarre stuff and lest anybody think
that ron watkins is the only wacky
candidate then the moderator asked
representative walt blackman about his
history of wanting to
charge
people women seeking abortions and the
doctors performing them with homicide
and he says he still supports that so
it's not only ron watkins that's off the
rails i read that you have said that you
said abortion doctors and women who get
abortions should be charged with
homicide exactly you know that's already
in our statute arizona statute if a
person commits abortion or kills a baby
while in the womb it's under our
criminal statute i didn't make the law
the law has already been there what i
did was codify that law now
going back and changing that and
amending that what i have done is allow
women to be able to seek services
counseling services
for what they need now here's the deal
so basically he's willing not to charge
women with murder
if instead they go to one of these
counseling services
where
the by the way the term counselor is not
a regulated term it's not a therapist
where they go to like a christian
counselor who talks you out of getting
the abortion there are more babies being
aborted and born every day now the
problem that i see is that that is not
part of the conversation and if i have
to do something to save the black
community of babies being aborted in a
record number guess what i'm going to do
it but we need to save all babies when
we have states like california and new
york that are pushing late term abortion
that are pushing and fantasize and we
stand and do and remember know what no
one's pushing it nothing it's time for
us to take a stand for life it's time
for us to get on the side of god and
it's time for us to protect these
children that are being murdered in the
womb homicide at what level how far did
the pregnancy be when it's homicide
conception conception conception yes sir
okay can you imagine
homicide
for a you know five-week abortion
this is this is
some people don't like this term this is
dark ages uh dark ages stuff
um okay one more clip the moderator asks
or one two more clips the moderator asks
ron watkins how would you have reacted
as a congressman on the day of the trump
riots we'll start with you how would you
have reacted as a congressman on january
6th on january 6 as a congressman i
would have
texted president trump and told him
please call this off
because it got out of hand pretty
quickly do you think he had the power to
do that
he did call it off but he took a while
to do this if he had the power to call
it off do you think he had the power to
call it on
i don't know uh
so he had invited all these people out
there
and
surely
uh there must have been some kind of
intel going on but i don't i don't know
it was meant to be a peaceful uh protest
and there were some people that got in
there and did some bad things and
those people should be prosecuted the
ones that did the bad things but right
for the majority of the people that were
there 99.99
it was a peaceful protest and there was
no issue so 99.99 of the people that we
saw on television storming the us
capital walking the halls defacing the
capital these were well i just told you
that there were people doing bad things
and there were millions of people there
and there was just a few people that
were really i've seen oh yeah the people
at that at that uh rally and at the
capitol millions yes sir yeah there were
not millions of people there as of
course we all know um and then lastly
here ron watkins actually asked about
his relationship to q anon he just
denies the entire thing ron some people
say that a lot of this was stoked by q
anon what is your relationship with q
anon i have no relationship with q anon
none at all none at all um the reports
are that your bulletin board sites
hosted postings that launched and
launched a q a on conspiracy so i ran a
free speech website and i was the
administrator
and there were many thousands of
thousands of people that posted on those
sites uh q was just one of those and i
do not know who it was and i'm not that
person yeah of course he spent months
and months and months parroting human on
stuff in uh cringeworthy fashion so
the closer we look at a lot of these
individual races it's all bad choices
it's bad
and then worse and unfortunately a lot
of these people may end up winning in
november we'll have these clips on our
instagram at david pakman's show who
though for those who were gluttons for
punishment and want to take a look at
them
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show it's great to welcome
back to the program today democratic
congressman rowe kana who represents
california's 17th district uh it's great
to have you back on and it's you know
the last time you were on was before the
russian invasion of ukraine so i think
maybe we would start there
uh weeks ago there were reports
seemingly credible reports that russia
sort of had the resources for about
another 10 days of what they started
with it's obviously been more than 10
days and what's taking place on the
ground has shifted to some degree
what's your outlook now based on what
you've been briefed on that you can talk
about about what what the longevity of
this might potentially be
well i don't underestimate the russians
in fact
charles lester had sent me an article
he's a
expert on what russia did in syria
just reminding us how brutal russia can
be and
they spent almost a
decade in syria
they did in aleppo
what they're doing now
to cities in ukraine and they've had the
same uh record in georgia so
i admire uh and support uh
unconditionally the ukrainian resistance
but i don't think we should be a rosite
in terms of uh
how difficult the this is going to be
and how
ruthless russia is
there are some uh including to some
degree noam chomsky and others who have
focused on the
what they see as the futility of
resistance against the overwhelming
power of russia and that ukraine should
essentially
give russia some stuff and try to end
hostilities as quickly as possible not a
perspective that many others
there are many others who very much
disagree with that perspective what's
your sense of what ukraine should be
doing
well my job as an american lawmaker is
to support ukraine and to provide make
sure we're providing them with military
weapons which we are make sure that
they're getting the resources that they
need make sure that president zielenski
has the unconditional support of the
united states i think the president has
done a tremendous job with secretary
blinken in rallying nato
i have called out countries like india
because i'm the vice chair of the indian
caucus saying we've got to be unified in
condemning
putin but i also have said that we have
to at the end of the day having
negotiated settlement and the united
states should be working uh towards uh
to do whatever we can uh before that but
strengthening ukraine and having this
resistance succeed uh i think is one
step to that because it weakens putin's
hand uh and putin has to be in a weak
position to even accept some uh
compromise i mean zelinski has floated
compromises he has said he's open uh to
uh
to seeing uh
even not even being neutral in certain
cases but
putin is the one as my understanding
isn't coming to the table
in terms of u.s troops on the ground joe
biden from the beginning said that
that's not something that he's willing
to do
and there's significant
support for that but not
total support for that red line
what's your position on on boots on the
ground
no and the president has been correct he
has been wise he's been restrained
he has done everything he can to support
the ukrainian people
but not
get us into a war with russia i don't
think anyone in america would want that
especially when you've got putin making
uh
terribly concerning statements about
using nuclear weapons against great
britain i mean the last thing we want to
do is to get into a
world war
two different things that are touchy to
say the least and if there's anything
you can tell us about them it would be
great one is increased speculation
including after a recent video that
vladimir putin is ill
looking swollen gripping a table just
very unhealthy appearance and lots of
speculation about that as a possible
factor in his actions on the other hand
speculation that
there has
without a doubt intelligence experts are
paid to provide all options to elected
officials and that it would be unusual
that the question of could putin be
assassinated would not have come up not
that anyone's planning to do it but that
this is what intelligence people are
paid to do provide every option can you
weigh in at all on either of those two
things
well i certainly not privy to any
knowledge that isn't out there
in the american uh public uh
so i i guess first i would just say that
it would be uh absolutely wrong and is
not the united states policy should not
be the united states policy to try to
assassinate a
sitting head of state of another country
and i would
vigorously oppose uh something like that
and it's nothing that i have heard of uh
being planned uh and i don't think in
any way is the policy of this
administration uh the second point about
putin's health i mean i've read about
the same speculation but uh i don't
think that uh can inform a policy uh we
have to
be governed by uh the basic facts of
what we can confirm and that is that we
need to continue to help the ukrainian
people
have as tough a resistance as possible
with the hopes that when putin is
sufficiently pushed back then we can
have a negotiated settlement last
question on this do you aside from what
would be acceptable responses to it
where it's a different question do you
agree with the perspective
that a nato expansion could legitimately
be seen as a form of aggression by putin
i don't think that is the cause of this
war i i think that the cause of this war
is what putin himself has written that
he wanted to see ukraine be part of uh
russia and uh that he views ukraine
historically as uh as part of russia and
that is uh his own words his own
rationale so uh we can put aside whether
the question on nato expansion and how
much to expand nato and what that
implication has for u.s security and u.s
russian relations uh but i don't think
it is anyway the proximate cause of this
war
okay so kind of on that note and into
this next topic there are uh
some on twitter and in sort of lefty
media circles that have sort of turned
on you in the last six months
and the idea being ro khanna isn't
progressive enough he's too friendly
with big tech
he's not willing to say something like
for example no listen i mean nato
expansion if if we had something
equivalent going on on our southern
border with a coalition involving other
countries we would absolutely see it as
aggression even if it's not the
proximate cause
do you believe that the criticisms of
you are fair do you feel like you've
changed in some way over the last six to
12 months that there's more sort of like
anti-rochana sentiment happening in some
of the usual places on the internet
i don't know do you think there is i
don't i i i haven't since that i know we
had a big i had a a big disagreement
with i think max blumenthal because i
basically support the president's policy
uh on ukraine and there have been people
who've been critical uh that i haven't
uh had a sort of
moral equivalence
between america and russia but i i don't
see that i think putin is a dictator who
is violating territorial sovereignty and
is uh clearly in the wrong here and that
he has to be resisted uh and i know
there's some people who are more
sympathetic
to putin's perspective uh on uh like in
max blumenthal's perspective i just
philosophically
disagree with that strongly disagree
with that and i'm much more on joe
biden's side than max blumenthal's side
and i guess maybe that has uh led to
some uh progressives being upset and i
guess the only other thing i've noticed
that some folks are upset is that i'm
speaking with senator manchin about
trying to get a climate deal
look i've been for the boldest vision on
climate uh i shared the big oil hearings
i
exposed a lot of their disinformation
for the last 40 years but i care so much
about the climate that i want to get
something done before the midterms and
you know if talking to to
senator uh
mansion uh
is unacceptable then basically people
are saying let's throw up our hands and
not get a climate deal that's not
acceptable to me yeah it seems to be
this debate that's not new about
pragmatism versus idealism which is
it seems in doing some research before
talking to you today that some of the
disappointment for lack of a better term
is that some feel
that
what was previously a much stronger
alignment with someone like bernie
sanders has shifted into being much more
accepting of the status quo and maybe
the mansion stuff is being perceived by
some
as being too accepting of the status quo
whereas it sounds like you see it as
being a realist and a pragmatist because
that's who you have to negotiate with
and work with right now
yeah and i look i've always been a
pragmatic progressive i've always been a
progressive capitalist i used to get
criticized when i was a bernie's
campaign as a co-chair
people saying oh why why are you making
this uh argument about how bernie is
an fdr and actually a progressive
capitalist uh and
why are you not
being more confrontational but i guess i
haven't changed i think people's baby
perceptions uh they're getting to know
who i really am and that is someone who
believes in medicare for all and has
fought for it free public college and
has fought for canceling student loans i
was just out in a rally and actually
publishing an op-ed in the post tomorrow
on it uh someone who's fought on yemen
against wars overseas but also someone
who believes in innovation believes in
entrepreneurship believes that
ultimately you you do have value in a
free enterprise system if it can be fair
with health care and education for
everyone and someone who's pragmatic who
wants to take the progressive movement
and say okay we gotta now get to the
fifty percent mark so that we can get
policy done
that's just one messaging so i think
describing me as a a pragmatic
progressive as someone who is a hundred
percent committed to the policies but a
more of a coalition building a little
bit more aspirational uh would be
accurate and and that may not be
appeal to everyone no politician can but
it is who i am and i would say it's been
consistent in how i have been since i've
been in congress
so let's talk about 2022 you and your
434 colleagues are up for re-election as
is always the case every two years we
also have some important governor's
races a third of the senate is up for
re-election elizabeth warren recently
wrote a piece where she says it's really
not looking good for democrats i tend to
agree
i am particularly worried because i look
at some of these races for example
monday in the pennsylvania senate race
to pick one yeah there was the
democratic debate where you have john
fetterman
and conor lamb and malcolm kenyatta and
a woman whose last name i believe is
khalil but i don't remember right now on
the democratic side on the republican
side you had this television doctor
mehmet oz as well as dave mccormick and
others in looking at it i love fetterman
on policy
his debate was i would call it
disastrous in terms of presentation and
when i looked at it i didn't i didn't
follow it i mean i yeah all the bernie
folks like him there i like him on
policy but when i looked at the five
republicans some of whom are bonkers i
mean they're out of this world nuts it
looks like any of the five would do
better in debates against the four
democrats that are running and mike
what do i need to learn for the future
he seemed disoriented to be perfectly
frank he seemed unprepared and and
confused at different times it was weird
i mean i would recommend that you watch
it but the greater point given that you
didn't didn't watch that in particular
is
i'm very worried that as terrible and
dangerous as some of the republican
candidates are
that the democratic party is is just not
prepared for what may be coming in
november and that it's going to be
absolutely brutal i mean what's your
outlook on the way it's looking right
now
it's a tough election and i think there
are two things we need to do one what
elizabeth warren has said forgive the
student loan pass something on climate
to excite our own base but i think it's
beyond that david and i uh
again i don't know people
everyone will agree with me but here's
what i think you know i was born in
philadelphia in 1976 our bicycle i still
believe this is the greatest country in
the world there are millions of people
who want to come to america and not go
to china i think democrats have to start
with that and then we need to say
there's a problem half this country was
de-industrialized the jobs were shipped
to china they were shipped to mexico and
50 percent of this country isn't
participating
in the wealth generation and producing
things uh while districts like mine have
wealth piling up and have been vetting
benefiting from globalization so we
understand why people are angry we
understand why they keep voting uh folks
out but we have a concrete plan to bring
good jobs to have reindustrialization to
bring economic prosperity to these
communities and we're going to start to
do it concretely just like bobby kennedy
did at bedford stuyvesant in 1964.
bringing business community labor
together and actually showing results
and i think we've got it if we lead with
that economic message of economic
revitalization look at the numbers today
with the gdp uh going down uh in the
quarter it's all because we're importing
things it's all because of the trade
deficit why can't the democratic party
become the party of reindustralization
economic revitalization that to me is a
not just a winning message it's a true
message and it gives us the best shot
in
i think winning back some of these
places well two two thoughts on that one
it's notably missing from the discussion
about reindustrializing and bringing
supply chains back home and both
republicans and democrats talk about it
we're going to do made in the usa trump
says it at every rally joe biden's been
saying it it's missing from that that
that will make stuff products
significantly more expensive and as an
economy over 30 years cumulatively
the u.s has opted for
cheaper stuff that's produced outside
the country we kind of have to deal with
the reality that everything would be
much more expensive if we brought all
supply chains back home wouldn't we
not necessarily david look i mean well
there are two points i mean yes it may
be more expensive instead of having
everything be made by uh slave labor
conditions in china and cheap imports
but the other possibility is that we
just massively increase productivity in
this country we massively increase uh
our uh capacity to to industrialize and
grow and that's what we haven't done you
know trump talks about it but he's not
actually articulating a industrial
policy of actually having the government
be providing purchase agreements and
loans in a massive scale with private
industry to bring production back
and i think biden we're doing it with
the competes act until putting 20
billion dollars in ohio but we could be
doing a lot more so
are you saying if there are two
alternatives which is okay get all the
cheap imports from china with slave
labor yeah that's always going to be
cheaper
than
building productive capacity in the
united states but building more
productivity and productive capacity in
the united states can also be
de-inflationary it'll be less
de-inflationary than just offshoring the
china but i would argue that most
americans would pick the round of
increasing our productivity instead of
uh importing from china both for
national security reasons and because of
moral reasons of having dignity if basic
workers are treated
so last thing on this and for today uh
on on the economic message i recently
watched a great netflix docu-series
about bobby kennedy and the economic
message worked extraordinarily well um
in his uh campaign cut too short right
in uh um in his era
he wasn't up against a republican party
that had very successfully weaponized
imaginary cultural issues critical race
theory
uh textbooks uh dr seuss uh you know
disney all these different things the
woke mind virus and all of these things
it's not feeling like the economic
message is um smothering these culture
battles that the right has created and
is fighting so what what should be done
i i just don't see the message getting
through
but it has to be an economic message
linked with american patriotism linked
with a hope and belief in the american
story when i i've gone to places like
paintsville kentucky beckley west
virginia galesburg illinois
in places like the west side of chicago
where manufacturing has left black
manufacturing is left and i talk about
my story my hope of america in my view
that
communities need to have uh the economic
opportunity uh for like kids in my
district have now it tends to break
through now i will grant this i'm
relatively unknown and so i haven't had
millions of dollars spent against me
making me a boogeyman
and maybe if i did it would be harder
than being relatively unknown but even
people who have more baggage i think if
you show up to these communities if you
actually are delivering something in
these communities and if you start with
i believe in america i believe we're a
good decent people i believe we are
going to remain the greatest country in
the world just every democrat may want
to start if they believe it i mean with
that paragraph and i think it puts
people at ease right now i think so many
people are wondering whether we
are judging them you know there was a
focus group in pennsylvania they said
republicans are crazy democrats are
preaching
we have to get a sense where we can
connect with people and say look we have
a real vision and all those other things
are distractions that's not going to
help your kids get a better life it's
not going to help us speak china we have
a real plan and we got to hammer that
talk about that again and again and
again and not get sidetracked uh
as they're trying to have us make do i
think it could work i do am i 100
confident no i mean that's why they have
elections yeah yeah no and the
difficulty is when those other issues
are meant to make people afraid that's
the basis of reactionary politics it can
be hard for the sober but positive
economic message to shine through but i
think that's exactly the challenge that
uh that that you're talking about uh
congressman ro khanna uh from california
17th district always great speaking with
you
thank you always enjoy it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
let's continue our tour of different
races across the country some of them
scarier than others today we're going to
look at california republican secretary
of state candidate rachel hamm who
uh has decided to run for office
because her son found jesus inside a
closet in her house
um this is really wacky stuff and we are
going to look at a couple of clips of
her here is rachel hamm again candidate
for secretary of state in california
she's a republican talking to us about
how she is trying to use prayer
to steal votes back so this this is very
convoluted
she believes democrats are stealing
votes
and she's going to pray
for god to send angels to steal the
votes back now why wouldn't god just
prevent the vote theft to begin with
we'll never know but take a listen to
this i would pray that i win
one thing that i've been doing is
praying that if anyone tries to steal a
vote that god would send the angels to
steal the vote back to make it an honest
vote yeah i think we might as well ask i
mean the angels are you know they can do
things they can do jobs so i think we
should get a lot of them are actually in
unions they prefer union work a job with
the election
help us make it an honest one so angels
if there are any fake ballots that have
been produced burn him up find him and
destroy him if votes are flipped in the
machines you know flipped away from the
candidate someone voted for flip it back
and i don't care which way if it's from
me to someone else because that's what's
honest just make it an honest vote right
so i'm not asking for cheating i'm not
asking the angels to cheat i'm asking
the angels to prevent cheating right now
with all of these things i always kind
of apply kind of like an occam's razor
thing which is
first of all if there is a god is god
really concerned with the election of
the california secretary of state or
would god be more worried about bigger
issues and then they can come back and
say well god is all-powerful and god is
all-knowing so god is involved in
everything god's involved in uh does
that banana uh that you ate uh does did
it does it have food poisoning are you
gonna get sick from the banana or is it
good god's involved in everything okay
well so why is she even running um she
explained that she's running because of
something about jesus being in her
closet what what was the
the
reason behind deciding to run for this
office i mean you've got a lot of things
first of all i'm a prophetic dreamer so
i had spent a lot of 2019 and 20 having
a lot of political dreams that i was in
office right and because our youngest
son ezekiel is a seer i went and got him
and i said hey can you look around and
see what you're seeing because and and
now there's a real question as to
whether
her son
through heredity became a seer or
whether it's something he learned
i i just really i get a kick out of
hearing him describe you know what he
sees and so i said you know let me know
if you see anything and so he looked in
my bedroom and my bathroom he said
there's nothing there and then he goes
into the closet which is where i had
been when i was praying right and he
said whoa and his eyes got like biggest
saucers and he kind of like started
backing away and they started bending
down and he said you've got a really big
guy in your closet and his power is
pushing me to the ground and he had
never had he'd never had that reaction
ever
to an angel and so i'm like is he he's
he's for us not against us right
and he's like he's full of why he's so
full of light i can't even see his face
and and then he said and he has a scroll
in his hand
and so i was like then he came with a
message like what is the message and the
message was a commissioning so at the
very end i asked him what his name was
because
what angel is this you know and he said
emmanuel
right that wasn't an angel
i wasn't an angel that was jesus himself
so
that's why i'm running for secretary of
state yeah it's kind of a she the kid
also found an angel in her washing
machine and then it turned out it was
actually um it was actually fabric
softener
uh so what do we do about that what how
what what i mean i guess hopefully she
loses we'll know that it was legit
because at this point god and jesus and
angels are so involved that if they
can't get her over the finish line
nothing can but
this is uh unfortunately this is very
common in the united states and i know
it's really scary for a lot of our
viewers around the world and for
children to hear this stuff because it
is pretty freaky
but um
that's a candidate that's a candidate
folks
we have a bizarre video this this is
actually
i have to tell you i love this video
this this really gives me pleasure
roger stone former trump confidant who
was convicted and then pardoned he has a
new tv show on lindell tv lindell tv is
this uh streaming channel
from
my pillow ceo mike lindell known
colloquially as pillow
and during what i think is one of the
debut episodes maybe the debut episode
roger stone has
complete and total technical issues
where the audio is completely unsynced
from the video
he is offering dog
he's offering dog pillows with a coupon
code my pillow dog pillows and then in
the midst of the technical aspects going
wrong
matt the engineer tries to interrupt to
get him to fix it and somehow stone
appears unable or unwilling to listen to
the engineer
but the audience hears the engineer i
mean you you can't write something
funnier than this check this out and i
know that if you're if you're only
listening
you won't see the visual aspect of the
audio and video being totally unsynced
so just imagine that as an additional
comedic element here you're an animal
lover and you want to do something great
for your pets go to my pillow right now
and use the promo code stone
later in the hour we're going to be
taking your phone calls in a segment we
call ask
roger right and that number for those
you want to plan ahead is 901
316-8404
once again later on ask roger
any topic political social style so by
multiple seconds the audio and the video
are disconnected and now the producer is
going to jump in this is beyond parody
or you want to talk about at 901
316-8404
today is an extraordinarily momentous
day for those who believe
in free speech
that's because hey this is matt here the
engineer is there any way you can send a
live feed back to us rather than a
delayed feed
twitter now this is more than just your
random billion oh this is just the best
so uh going out on a lighter note today
folks a lot of serious news today but a
little bit of a palette cleanser there
everything going wrong
uh on roger stone's new show we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p the topic of tipping continues
to
titillate the audience the eggman
calling in with another tipping related
question
hey dave i have a question about tipping
when you're traveling in europe guys so
you know i lived in italy for almost a
year many years ago i married a
foreigner right um we went out to eat
often and they don't tip there obviously
right so i'd have a meal and i would
leave a tip sometimes i would get a
dirty look from the wait staff for
leaving them a 20 tip on top of the meal
i felt weird about tipping right and so
the i guess in some countries when you
leave a tip
it's seen as
you think the restaurant must be
struggling so you leave them extra money
that's why in some places it's seen as
offensive to tip and then
when i wouldn't tip because you just
don't tip i'm paying a lot for this meal
i felt like then i would get a dirty
look like dude we know you're american
you can't come here and not tip yeah
americans have to tip here only italians
don't have to tip here
so dave have you ever noticed any of
those things shallow brother yes shalom
i have noticed those things there
sometimes there's a bit of a double
standard on tipping
my v again i'm against tipping i just
like price everything in and i'll decide
if it's worth it you know and then it
ignores it avoids all of these travel
problems and cultural you know
inconsistencies on tipping that being
said i will play the game i will look up
what is expected in each country and in
some countries it's like now you just
round up to the next dollar okay in some
countries it's like five to ten percent
max for good service but not expected
and i just try to do what's expected i
agree it's all horrifying now i will say
um my experiences in italy were
everybody wants a tip there was once a
um i stayed at a hotel
in the amalfi on the amalfi coast and i
think there were six different
opportunities for tips as soon as i
pulled up in my rental car someone came
out and wanted the keys in order to park
the car so that was tip opportunity
number one tip opportunity number two
was the person who insisted on bringing
my luggage into the hotel tip number
three was the person who insisted on
bringing the luggage from the lobby up
to my room tip number four was the
person who came up to the room and
insisted on giving me an a full tour
including like how light switches and
toilets work it's like i'm not trump i
know how toilets work i'm not going
around thinking i have to flush them 10
to 15 times and fifth opportunity for
tipping was when you want the rental car
they put it in a lot where you could
easily just walk into the lot and get it
but it they get it for you so it creates
a fifth opportunity for leaving a tip so
it was tip crazy in uh in in italy you
should have seen what was going on all
right
great bonus show for you today just
trust me i won't even tease what's on
today's bonus show it's a good one sign
up at joinpackman.com